Good evening everyone, I was
told I have to get as close to the
microphone as possible so that everyone can
hear, so it's nice to be able to speak in this
wonderful old lecture hall,
remind myself of the old
days, which also says something about my age,
but nice as I said here
I would like to warmly welcome you, Mrs.
Senator, tonight,
nice that you
are with us at this Zurich meets Berlin event, but
I also welcome Mr. dos Santos
Pinto, who is also among us Wald, nice that
you are also there and we
still have  panelists who
are also here
I already said this evening as
part of the Berlin science week this
format back
to the topic of sustainability
continue together for sustainable development
well I don’t think it’s of any great value
to waste big words
about the importance of the topic
Sustainability I think
we are all more than aware of that. What I
personally find great about this format
is this exchange of
information, this exchange of
knowledge, this exchange of opinions
between universities in Zurich and
here in Berlin, I also say
symbolically for the obviously super
moderately functioning cooperation
that we have support and also in the
research area between our
two cities, so not only as
right here Humboldt the Free
University of Berlin has a network with the University of
Zurich the
University of the Arts is obviously one of the
most important partner organizations
of our Kunsthochschule Zürich so the
list could
we will of course try to
keep our connection to Europe keyword because Horizon 2020 is
a bit stuck at the moment but hope dies
last and Germany
also supports us a lot in it and
we are very grateful for that today I do
n’t want to be here longer  I would
like to hand over the floor to you,
Mrs. Senator, I will come
back with some
information about the course of
the evening, but thank you very much for coming here in large numbers
and have fun and lots of information, thank you
very much  thank you
[applause]
yes, good evening, dear Mr.
Ambassador dr Seeger, dear
scientists, students, dear
guests of the Science Week from Zurich and
Berlin and wherever you come from,
we are very international here with the Science Week,
you are all very
welcome  It is a very
great honor for me and really a great
pleasure and pleasure to be
here with you this evening,
Mr. Ambassador, and with you
all here at the Berlin Science-Weg
and here at this great event, the great
Zurich meets series of events
Celebrating Berlin with them, one almost has to
say, is much too serious for what
we are doing here, but instead enjoying them, they
enrich our science festival this year
with an incredible 20
events and four exhibitions in a wonderful way.
and canton of Zurich together
with the Syrian universities  Contribute to the
program and I am particularly pleased
that four universities
are participating: the University of
Zurich, the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology, the Zurich University of
Applied Sciences and the
Syrian University of the Arts
Here in Berlin you will also find an
extremely rich
scientific ecosystem with over 40
universities  and around 70
non-university
research institutions that is
almost unique in Europe in this density
for several years three
of our universities, the free university, the
Humboldt University and the Technical
University, together with the Charité, have
briefly come together to form the Berlin University Alliance and these
successful institutions overarching
and  Also for Berlin, this is still a
new type of cooperation that builds
bridges to many other actors,
the scientific collections, the
museums, we see that very strongly here today,
also here in this place, and
cultural and political
institutions, such as start-ups and partners
from industry, the Berlin University
Alliance  is therefore working intensively on
creating an integrated research area in Berlin the individual
scientific connections between
Zurich and Berlin have existed for many
years and at various
levels in the last five years
these cooperations have also been provided with a
somewhat more formal framework with
three Berlin university
institutions maintaining the  The University of
Zurich has now had strategic
partnerships with the FU Berlin since
2017, with the HU since 2019 and the
Charité was added in 2020. If you
think about connections between Zurich and Berlin in the scientific field, then it is inevitable that
you can of course still look back to much earlier
collaborations or
connections  more and that is
inevitably associated with a very
famous name with Albert Einstein in
1914, the then 35-year-old moved from
his professorship at the ETH to Berlin
so we practically poached him
from the knowledge and they apparently didn’t
negotiate well at the time  he
always went to Berlin to Berlin as a
science location,
but of course he remained particularly closely connected to Switzerland throughout his life, even after
emigrating to the United States,
and his field of research, the
theory of relativity, was
groundbreaking at the time, of course, and the
consequences we
still see 100 today  Years later, just
this year, again at the Physics
Nobel Prize,
you could clearly see that again,
but a completely different type of
highly topical subject area of ​​global
importance is the focus tonight
and that is sustainable development,
and here you have to say that the
approach of the research approaches alone
makes a difference  now
fundamentally from what we
now see in the theory of relativity, because
here it is
essential that science,
society, economy and politics face
the challenges
together and the close exchange
about our future in a
responsible and sustainable
way  to shape and metropolises
Zurich Berlin with their urban
forms of society but also in their
function as engines as
innovation engines these are of course
the
places where something like this can happen
and the and metropolises play a
very special role here, so I’m
not
only extremely happy tonight  welcome the Rector of the University of Zurich
Professor Michael
also Ms. Anna Schindler we
have seen each other in a
video message I don't know if
you have seen me I have seen you
I have seen your video message
the Director of the City of
Zurich Development the architects as well
the city planner Mr. mando dos Santos
Pinto and with many with them many
other representatives from Zurich and
Berlin scientific and
social institutions and
business enterprises it
is also very pleasing how prominently the universities
of applied sciences are
represented in the program tonight
these universities are standing up
special way of
linking academic research
and teaching with the regions in which you
work and there is also
long-standing and very successful and
close cooperation in the form of a
joint double master's program from
the HWR Berlin and the Zurich
University of Applied Sciences
Finally, I would like
to take the opportunity once again to
thank the guests from Zurich for the visit
and I have to say again that
we are always extremely impressed with the
professionalism, commitment
and intensity you organize this event here in Berlin
and enrich it
that is really very unique and
we are happy and I think it is
also worthwhile it has been worth it according to
everything I have heard so far
if the opportunity arises from
these encounters on this evening to establish
contact between Zurich and Berlin on the
subject of sustainable development  but also
to further develop and deepen the scientific area as a whole, then
we are very happy to do so, ladies and
gentlemen, I wish us all a
very exciting evening, good impressions,
good discussions and a lasting
exchange between Zurich and Berlin,
thank you very much
[applause]
yes, many heartfelt ones  Thanks to Mrs. Senator
for these introductory, very
friendly words 2-3 sentences now about the
course of tonight you have
already touched on Mrs. Senator we will
now start with an input presentation
from Mr. Mandl through Santos Pinto he
is an architect and expert in
sustainable urban development and will
us  the introduction give an insight into the
most important folk factors in
cooperation for sustainability,
then a
panel discussion on the subject of visions of
cooperation between Berlin and
Zurich where we
exchange ideas about
how we can promote sustainability at the
urban level and I
was a  few years also at the UN
according to UN statistics
today already 50% of the world population live
in urban regions I have 2050
will be 70 percent of the people who
live in cities so I think this
topic what the cities
can do for sustainability will be today and
in  The future will not
become irrelevant quite the opposite,
then after the
panel discussion 5 breakout sessions where
you can deal in depth with challenges of a
thematic nature
and then maybe the highlight
of the evening I don’t know the
Swiss aperitif not then there will be
something after work
to eat and drink something small where they
can then continue to maintain the network and the conversations wow that was already
as far as the process is concerned I am
very much looking forward to a lively exchange of ideas with you
and I would like to thank you on
this occasion
the senator for the cooperation with
the speakers for
the preparations, also from my
point of view also from the Berlin side,
a big thank you for the great
preparation so now let’s film thank you
very much [
applause] dear
ambassador dear
senator dear  participants I am
very pleased
to be able to present here today and to be able to give an input
on the topic of sustainability, my
core area and the success factors for
cooperation
about me I am an architect and
urban planner and I develop
sustainable solutions for cities in the
Global South, mainly in
African cities and in the Global
North  mostly in Zurich Berlin a
bit everywhere in Switzerland
I thought about it a lot
because I love Berlin I love Zurich
what should I bring from my
various projects should I for
example the ecocar project so empty where
we in Dakar the minibuses the 20%  of
public transport on the solar
wall
or should I present a new project that we
are just starting because it was
also possible to convert
materials afterwards where we had the first building in
Dakar in the center with a spin on the
ETH that would have been a good fit
just a recitable  is a building that
means building without cement
I decided on the liquid water project
we are in times of crises some
crises are over some are still here they are yet to
come and this picture what you
see here is a vision from the
beginning of the project  there were
2 million people living in Dakar
due to the climate crisis in
risk areas because of the heavy
rainfall 2 million people that is
enormous that is a third of the city of
Berlin a quarter of Switzerland
who live three months a year in
such conditions
as we knew it here too
2021 that's in the Karl every year so
this street you saw the other picture just now
so be it
from these heavy rains
everything is carried down there people
try to protect their houses with rubble
to protect the foundations because every now
and then a house collapses
down in the same quarter that at the end of
the street then all the water comes
and what happens new lakes
came into being the houses flooded
school buildings which were mostly built afterwards
in which the
whole thing is not a suitable place for
children but for everyone  People and
mostly like everywhere a crises are
most affected the most vulnerable
our society
what do we do we know it
goes on like this in
Berlin for the church the
people have glued themselves on the streets
that is the solution
how do we get the sustainability
from my experiences  in projects with
conversation we have to involve the people
and the picture how we involve in
this project libid water with the
people with all people
and make the right participation goal
is to know they are the experts
the people who are affected these are
the real ones  Experts who show us
where to go what are solutions we
come up with solutions but they are
always being improved together with you
we work on a vision a
vision that carries us through the entire project
that is supported by everyone
then I thought Berlin science gone
I'm something
knowledge-based 1&1 equal to three what
does that mean when one person
comes together with another then it's
not two but the knowledge of what is
generated together is always more
than the individual people
would have found out individually and I think that's
when we talk about success factors
a very important one for me and
we will have the opportunity
to try it out later in the world card rooms, then it takes know-how
and know-how transfer and among other things
I chose this project
because they have a responsibility here,
especially when the climate crisis is going on
we have a responsibility in Europe
and cities like Berlin
and Zurich have the potential for
renewal, they have the potential for
know-how and the know-how if we
don't anchor it then we'll go
away again and nothing has happened that is
quite a lot in the collaboration unfortunately
a few things then it's about the
implementation
and very important light and projects
why lighthouse we when I
started this project we thought
okay I also need something newer
urban gardening okay we'll bring that
in first it was just  an idea but when we
then put that in to
drain the water there were all
those hard factors with the
sanitary performance and so on but
the guarding sounded like a soft factor
but in the end it was the
most important factor because the water was the the
before  the quarter
had flooded could now be used for urban
agriculture the zones
that you saw earlier
were full of waste no one dares
to put waste there anymore and it generated
new income for the local people
so the problem
we had had actually increased
developed as a bonus for society
that's how it looked before
nobody dared to go around there after 6
a.m. when it was dark because the small
crime was
mosquitoes anyway everyone put the rubbish
there and that's how it
changed
what's the deal with Berlin and Zurich
to do
we have a team and that's the
other people factor
set up a transdisciplinary team to
find these solutions we have
very different partners but
we had very important partners who wake up
a part of the ETH specializes
in water and
sewage  then global
contact who organized the entire financing
of the project without them
it would not be possible is a
Berlin company and our company that
developed the concept and limited it
so we can do so much and the
ambassador has already announced I did
n't know anything else  I would
n't have brought the dress now but I think that
's a very important networking
Apero this culture and many Berliners
when they come back to Zurich
they say Aperol no I don't like Aperol
no it's not Aperol and it's
not coffee and cake
either  it's really coming together
with enjoyment, the
best projects ideas and the best
contacts develop so the input
if you want to contact me
you can just scan it is the
easiest and otherwise just
come to me and I would like to
pass the word on then I  I think the
input for me was to show how we can make a
difference and how we should think out of the
box or in the box,
depending on that, but we have a lot of
responsibility for the world that we
can carry and we can make a lot
more difference if we work together
thank you very much
[applause]
first of all thank you very much man I
'm Dominik Meyer I'm now moderating
the next small part with my
penelist
great Manu how can you
give me a better transition than saying what is
what we are doing it is dialogue and
cooperation and proving that  we
Switzerland proves that we prove it
here in Berlin and cooperation across
borders the future is very global
that's why I'm happy that I
have experts there for experts from all
shades I'm
just happy to come across Reuter Michael because if
you  want to spend the next 30 minutes here
together,
thank you, sir, before you introduce them, please don't worry,
not just a stone, but someone
who died around the corner who lived on this street is
entitled to his death,
who also lived for many decades between
Berlin and Zurich
I found out quite amusingly that he
wrote his great works in Berlin, like
the life of Galilei or Mother
Courage, and do you know where the
premiere was in Zurich, so
too much of that
wonderfully fits between Einstein and Brecht,
I don't think there are many between,
um, welcome  I am
very pleased that you are here. I would like to
introduce the ladies and gentlemen very briefly to you. Prohibitions are clear. She is very active in
science, so
she is your contact person here
the most difficult tasks
you can ever have in Berlin
or in Germany in general
very briefly they had been in Kassel before that
and otherwise they come from the deep
south for the last 20 years she was a
Bavarian member of parliament for a long time and in the end she was
also vice president of the Bavarian
state parliament  and yes, it lost its heart to
the Greens in 1996, at least you can say a
warm welcome, woman, that you
are here and important as a transition for the
rector of the university, you
studied ecology and Professor
scheppmann Michael scheppmann is a
geographer if I
got it right and then  Hardcore
experimental physics I know and everything
here high scientist
scientist and computer science then
learned a lot because a lot on the way
then came back to Zurich in 2009 and has
a chair for a great title
for an ailment namely
remote sensing at the Geographical Institute
of the University of Zurich what he told me
completely  exciting and that's why I'm glad
that you're here for
your lecture again he looks at the
world from orbit towards earth
so to speak a modern consultant like me top
download so we're very curious what
you will tell us afterwards and
but
woman  Judgment has already been briefly mentioned
who
I think has been in charge of urban development
in the city of Zurich for some time now, but what
connects you both Herrmann
both geographers
so you also
studied geography in Bern you just have to make
an effort um then
been a journalist  I wrote a lot about building and living for a long time and
also
received prizes for my work after that, how
is that supposed to happen? I also went to a university,
ten of them are the Zurich University
of Applied Sciences, they have
already
particularly evoked the applied sciences
and I found that since 2011
you city development director
welcome with us
but we also have a very exciting person
next to us because today
herbs if it's true and don't
be angry if it's no longer true he
has a grocery store on
Invalidenstrasse is exactly right but that
was just the start  not only that I
really think he has a creative mind he has an
agricultural engineer makes you sustainability
also has a company
great name advice green heads
sustainability advice I would
sum it up but very exciting so
he founded something and later in the
breakout there is also the futcampus
Berlin that spoke New High German
such an incubator for start-ups how do
we find cool solutions for the
food industry of tomorrow so thank you very much I
'm super that you
're here we have a good 30 minutes
because you finally want to
do something else yourself, namely discuss it
I would jump in very briefly  to
loosen up what is
sustainability maybe Mr. Reuter in
two sentences
exactly better like the regeneration of the
rather stressed planetary boundaries
that is sustainability if we
manage to create a world for 10
billion people without it
being destroyed people too
so for me sustainability is if
I can tell my children that my
research has made a substantial contribution
to improving the
sustainability of the earth
for me it is to live in such a way that those who
come after us, our children, grandchildren, great-
grandchildren, still have the same degrees of freedom
that we have today and the
same biodiversity and  I think it's great
to find the same or good environmental quality. I
think they
all briefly said it's about the
future and sustainability and the
question of how life will be in the next
generations how can we see a whole
orbit the whole world to be
responsible  bring
your examples together again and that
's the topic tonight and it's enough
err first
excuse me Professor
Collaboration Zurich Berlin Rad
Urban Development or in general
maybe a bit in there what are
you doing right now how is it going right now
and maybe a few wait a minute
about that  we all get a sense of what they are
doing here in the collaboration
yes, I think the best place to start is
that we are currently
working very hard on poaching as many colleagues as possible
from the
Berlin universities so that
they work at the University of Zurich,
we are more successful  or less good
we have done particularly well in
urban development we have recently had
Hannah Hilbrand with us at the
University of Zurich, who is the only
professor at the University of Zurich who is currently
dealing with urban development and the question is do
we need tutoring or can we do
anything  return to Berlin I
'll put it from a higher
altitude we are partners in various
alliances, for example in a
trilateral agreement between Vienna
Berlin and Zurich we meet
regularly we are a European network partner together with the
FU Berlin in Unna Europe
and you can see that
hundreds of small contracts
work together and various
activities take place between the University of Zurich and
the Berlin institutions,
so I think this is our strongest
network
of the University of Zurich abroad, so
from that point of view I would say the
cooperation works very well, I
also suspect that we work culturally  are very
similar, even if we talk very often about
Lake Zurich, which we don't
know very well, we know Lake Zurich
better, but I think that can
still happen in time, great, thank you very much,
we have to be careful
because I'm coming to you with the political question
right away but understand that because
urban development so zentime now as the
responsible city developer in
Zurich you have seen the pictures of
Manu
how do you evaluate what is what you say
is the most important points of
scientific urban development because
what is what can you do to do such
things  Not having pictures anymore
what is going on how can the university help what
can Zurich and Berlin
do together to prevent the pictures I
don't know I don't know if they
can be prevented but I mean we
work, I think in research and
in  the cooperation on this, we in
Zurich, for example, in
international cooperation
together with other cities, it is
fairly new and with
implementation partners who then
implement the projects, we are working on
improving the framework conditions
so that knowledge can also be imparted, and
then the universities will also come along  into the
game I don't know if you
can prevent them completely, but I think it's
very, very important for us at the
city level, too, what the rector
had already said at the university, that we
work together, that we
have connections abroad with other cities,
that we're here  In Berlin, where we have
actually had an exchange for a long time
at the political level,
administrative level at the university, there is also
an exchange at eye level, whether it is
in international cooperation,
which I think is in the direction of
development cooperation, or
in temporary cooperation on
specific topics, such as how
urban development can be
Being cycling in the city and
as far as I think one of the most important things
that cities, especially Swiss cities
and I don't assume, of course, have
to do is work together and
think beyond their own borders
great what does the practitioner say about this so
food Campus Berlin every day every
week  people are confronted with
urban development who experience
or suffer live depending on so that's
not so easy to answer so
there is of course with
increasing urbanization and so on
there is always the romantic
idea that we could make the cities out of
the cities  feeding out with
food projects that doesn’t necessarily have to be that way,
but of course we have
very, very large leverage
with food in the context of sustainability, so food
has a very, very strong impact negative
impact on the planetary boundaries food
is made responsible for 30% of greenhouse gases
for 70% of
biodiversity losses
and we have to create places where solutions are
developed and the food campus
is one of those that Zewen wants to become
because the future food campus that is
being built there at the same time is a different place
and I think we have a very
good collaboration on that level as well
in both standing solution
that are globally important
can only look at because this is in front of the
door
where do you think what can be
done better where in the foot campus
just your experiences where do you think
bureaucracy can make something easier where
I don't have science better
working together, which Mr. Reuter,
I think things are going quite
well, I have to say, especially
in the cooperation with the ZAW, that
's actually really great
fun and collaboration
always involves people,
skills, common visions, and
we share that very strongly  and I do
n't want to get into the whining song about what
else the city could do for us, there
are certainly, you can
always make a lot of wishes from
politics, but to be honest, at the food
Campus Berlin we take matters into our own
hands and then rock quite a bit  big
project do
you want to say something about it you
are the same as the head of urban development
so
I see it the same way with the support I mean we are happy
about every initiative that does it yourself
no you asked where Hoppert
is it doesn’t necessarily have I think
in  First and foremost in the cooperation
he has that when you
take back mutual knowledge and experiences and then implement them at
home, I would say, because I
think there are those who have the
greater difficulties, but often
go out and exchange ideas, learn
from each other, that's still there  not the
point point is taking it home
and then bringing it back in the
applied form of how do I get the
science into the house I
mean I also often talk about politics
my life is also administration
and politics of course also
science  but simply insights
that you see, good things that are also very
practical in other cities that you
would like to take over and then you have your
own reality at home
that is not always so open and what does
the rector say that the university
wants to steal from the students
I always say that if
student exchange programs
were a free trade agreement, then each
party would cancel the agreement with us.
We have the problem that the
mobility of Swiss students
is, let's say, um, moderate compared to others. That
means we're trying there and I think I'll
say that now  casually, if
the Rhine Valley railway can be used a little
faster, then the
exchange
will work better again and we will also
get a lot of Swiss people to Berlin in this
exchange, but I also think when I
look at the student exchange numbers that you actually do
loves coming to Berlin from Switzerland
and knows wonderful words,
thank you very much for
listening to me for so long, but that’s the
question for you, so first of all you got good
grades, congratulations, I don’t think that
’s always the case in Berlin politics,
but that  shows the global
cooperation who always understands the Berlin
intercultural the global the
connecting what are you planning to do to
advance the development of science in Berlin
and gives a little secret what
we want to tell us what you
want to do extra with Zurich yes so what  what
we think I have just heard
is we the question is one is
always asked what can we learn from Zurich
or what can you
find Zurich to learn from Berlin it is even more important
to ask like 1 + 1 = 3 yes what
can we do  learn together and that's where
the added value lies in the fact
that I, for example, also get together with metropolises
that tick in a similar way they
called it similar cultures and still
manage to achieve a change of perspective
because that's always the benefit of
every committee  but
to change one's own perspective and also to question what
one believes to have already recognized
and to know again
or to illuminate it from the other
point of view that's
the great thing that happens with exchange
and everything that goes in this direction  of
course we want to
deepen and strengthen it on an
informal but also on a formal
basis that is certainly what always
arises from such encounters
should not be underestimated from such
an aperitif back there later there
can definitely result in a concrete cooperation in the end
are the places
where creativity actually
leads to action that I think is very good
what is very important for us here at the
Berlin location is
transdisciplinarity and of course we absolutely need that
for the challenge of
sustainability and
I said it at the beginning in the greeting
that  Science is part of it,
but the entire
urban society is also part of it, all
areas and that is of course what
we see in these dense metropolises
in an
experimental laboratory and
can also try it out and especially
recommended for those who are also open-minded  that are
internationally positioned that
attract young people sometimes it works
like in an incubator yes that you
actually make progress a little faster that
's what we like to
promote, so this
exchange and the inclusion of all
stakeholders in this whole goal of
sustainability that would be that  what we
want to move
something special what you want to do now
between Berlin and Zurich where you
say that is a special area that
also promotes the future of urban development
or sustainability in
scientific research
so the keyword was just
given that experimental laboratory
we call it real laboratory but the idea
is exactly the same the universities
are instead universities and
universities in the city have to
give a helping hand to society
that means the ivory tower is
definitely a thing of the past but what does
that mean for a future
perspective for universities
universities in the city can  Yes, we
also live with the city and
do experiments with the city and I think
we have sometimes
lost sight of the trend that global
movements are becoming more and more important, but
maybe we should also
look around regionally and see what
can we actually achieve
together  why does a lecture hall
always have to be at a university why ca
n't our students enjoy their lessons at
a company or with someone
else that means
that we also strengthen spatial mobility
perception of space in different
situations why ca
n't we visit each other
when they  come to think of it i was
socialized with lecture
school lessons they were all 50 minutes
i don't know who came up with the idea
that my
attention span is 50 minutes
but obviously we've been
trained so why can't we just
go somewhere else for 10 minutes and
then create a system  where the
cooperation is already cultivated
if you
do it outside of the university, for example, so
in the future we could really
consider
offering further training or, as it is modernly called, microcodancials, i.e. short, small lecture parts at other places
they wanted to immediately
I just mentioned the Bua
and it also came up in the lecture
who are actually the experts,
we really ask who the experts
are in their own right and so
we are currently developing
the search for new ones with the Boa  Topics according to
the major research fields according to the
grand challenges that we now
want to occupy together with students that
is complex that is exhausting yes that does
not always lead directly
to the goal but I believe that
the future is really all from the beginning  to
include and also those who you do
n’t necessarily think of at first
and who you yes where you
said before then there they should first
learn and study something and then
we ask you exactly that is wrong but
you have to do it right from the start
most concerns involve
exciting there is such a real laboratory with
you in the city of Zurich I was
actually saying something else with the
involve I will come to the
substance of the spinality later I think that
one is to involve it
is very important that  other is
also about sustainability and I
'm also geographically
thinking about sustainability really so broadly we often talk about sustainability
in my ecology and that's also an
approach for people in Zurich and it
sounds so simple but it's also that
economic, she says social
sustainability, that means we need
an economy that works in such a way that
we can get the right companies here,
that we can find solutions in the
area of ​​sustainability,
but we also need a social awareness that
the measures we then take are
not for that purpose  lead to people
eventually paying so high rents that
they can no longer live in the city
and so on, so I think that
goes one step further for me than
including everyone, of course, that's
difficult, participation is never an
easy field, but I think it is  It's
also about leading this discussion broadly
and also leading it openly
but we don't have to answer
the question now do you
still want answers
no no but I saw another sentence
to learn I mean that sounds so good
it is I think it  always nice
when you talk about it in the city of
Zurich I don't know how many in real terms
but or in that sense
we really have that we try with taxpayers' money
and then
start from scratch Berlin is maybe a
bit more open because I think they have
pop-  up- Fahrrad they made and so on
but the real lab itself with this
experimental character that's just
difficult in an urban context
we might do that together with the
universities
and
before that we look further at you're a
practical man they advise you  so many
companies are
on the move in different worlds how do
you see because experimenting on this
level in this city,
in that context, the whole of Berlin would
certainly be a real laboratory in many
respects, everyday here
with us, so I don't think I'm
the right contact person
here  is very clear focus we want to
turn big wheels the food industry we are talking
about 300 billion sales in
Germany and they want to
bring about the transformation so that is
our focus and I am happy about all the
projects that are being created around it but
I would agree with them  our
focus is on the topic of food and
industries I think there are many
other exciting projects and real laboratory
tests in Berlin great then I have to
look at the clock otherwise I'll get in
trouble from the organizers
here um but I was asked that we  Let's
all look to the future together because we've
seen that we have to shape the future together
and the starting point of my
question is I think that we all
agree and I'll give that I
might call it with two key words
you always use one sentence
from an event or from a
conversation, that’s usually how we were
taught as consultants
we need open universities, we
need open cities,
the openness to overcome borders and
also to find borders in our heads between
science, society, politics,
economy, I think that’s a
crucial point  and start
development is exactly what is
open together that's even for
me from the now almost 30
minutes but right before the doors she's
the first I'm sorry but you think
a lot about how
this open city culture looks like  you
think in five five years politically five years
or ten years we have ten years
now I want to give
a pulse it's not just about
ecology I'm a geoecologist myself I
like to talk about ecology but I'm
also a health senator and
senators for equal opportunities a goal here
Equality for women is also a matter of sustainability and that is
where we have come a long way in Berlin
and where we still
have room for improvement. I think that is something
very concrete that we in
urban societies, especially in large
urban societies, still do in all
areas  have to live better that
women really occupy half of the power,
half of the money, half of the
economy and the knowledge fairly fairly in all areas on all levels right up to the top, so
that's one big goal and the
second is where it's at  about the social
dimension of sustainability I would be
very satisfied if I could do my part here in Berlin
in the near future so
that we
all have good access to
health care that
is up-to-date and easily accessible  picking
up people where they are, namely
in their neighborhoods, in their needs,
based on what the
individual needs, that would be a
challenge, especially in the
metropolises, where one always thinks that
the supply is not so great at all
is and where we
have to work a lot on the detail on
the individual level in the neighborhood
into the community
heartfelt thanks is a clear claim
what what does the University of Zurich say about well well
over 10% of the population
in Zurich  Students and if we
want to ensure that the
attractiveness of the location
remains guaranteed and you
all know for sure that Zurich is not the
cheapest place, we have to
ensure that the total costs of the
education, i.e. total education,
are in competition with other locations
and these other locations are
simple  times the biggest competitors where
universities are very expensive but
also offer a lot of
additional services if now in Zurich
the apartment prices continue to rise
we will push our students out of the
city
even further on public transport and make sure that we have
a location disadvantage over time like that
so for me the
most important thing is that the students can live and live
close to the universities within a reasonable commute time
so
that we can ensure that our
location
activity is maintained and I think
that is the most important thing for us there are
various activities in Zurich in
the  Switzerland to promote student accommodation
I think that a good
distribution of the different social
classes in a city is very very important at the moment.
Thank you very much
We won't let housing policy on that, I do
n't think here in Berlin either,
housing policy is a huge issue in the
city of Zurich  be pushed
out and that it can grow in such a way
that it continues to prosper at
a high level that is correct, but that
we can do it all in
a sustainable way and I
won’t come back to the cooperation it also requires cooperation
on a small scale  Borders beyond with
the neighboring communities with the canton with
the federal government and the big but also in the
international area otherwise come along
so you can’t isolate yourself
otherwise you won’t get any further so you
actually have the last word
so now I’m slowly becoming an
urban development expert here  I
see it in two directions, so
as I said, addressing a
global topic and seeing this
magical, restless city of Berlin as an
exciting starting point for a
worldwide network of food campi that
with the ZEW was the start we
made today with our
memorandum Boston  Coming next is
Singapore and Rwanda Kigali, it's our
turn so that's the setup
and what you just said locally we
have to do a lot, I think for us it
's also enormously important for us to grow together with
Brandenburg from Berlin, with the
surrounding area and we'll talk  yes,
about food and it makes total
sense to get closer together here because,
despite all the love for some kind of gardening
and whatever else there is, our
food is ideally produced around Berlin
in Brandenburg, so I
think we also have to think about the rural
regions here,
a wonderful key  when you were
forbidden I would like to say
thank you very much for listening I
hope we take something with us I think it has
always become clear that sustainability concerns
us all it doesn’t matter where you are how
you are what you do it is our great
common challenge and  It's
not just a
garden, it's also a hospital, it's also
care, of course, it's also the
food industry, so to speak, and above
all it's total balance and in
that sense I wish you a nice
weekend, a nice evening and now
I'll pass it on because now it's your turn
the breakout session  wait and
cure we'll take over and will
tell you what's next before the
[applause]
yes thank you very much let me explain a little
how to proceed now as you
know there are five different
breakouts some of them have
already signed up others can sign up
now  decide spontaneously
which Ray Card you want to participate in
stay here in the auditorium those who are
interested in the breakout water in biodiversity and climate crisis then we have
the next breakout right in the anteroom, it's
about building materials in the cycle
and then the other three have to
move  back in the museum
they are then closer to the aperitif so
my colleagues have signs from the
various projects
future of food is in the collaborative
field please just hold up the sign
these two episodes
and then the next one the sustainable
economy and sustainable
urban development will take place in
mineral space instead of sign
urban development over there
follow these two gentlemen and then we
also have the deep tight forum it's about
the financial topic how you can
invest sustainably with artificial intelligence
there i pray the
signs to go to the door and
maybe in the anteroom to  and then
hold up the signs and then
deploy
well, I think we're all
very welcome to the breakout
session so far, nice that you've
stayed here, we're not a
big group, but that's an advantage, we
can really talk together
and  deepen certain topics
our title is water in the
biodiversity and climate crisis how
successful communication and adjustments
the sheet was already
opened today and our goal is to deepen a
few selected aspects of the panel from
tonight and from noon
and also in a technical and
personal exchange we
want a few hotspots directly from
committed researchers personal
experience this is the chance in this
breakout situation and I hope we
will also hear a few stories of
success I myself am Niklaus
Heep I am not an expert on the topics of
biodiversity and the climate crisis  I am a
designer and scientific illustrator
from the Zurich University of the Arts,
but I am in charge of the
knowledge visualization department there, so they are up
close and personal in
cooperation with the beings and I
and my research group, we have been working
with Andreas Linzbauer for several years,
then may you introduce yourself  we
now have andreas linzbauer i am a geographer
and glaciologist at the geographical institute of
the university of zurich and as niki
said we have been working together for a long time
how to deal with the
climate crisis in communication as well
how to reach people
how to
proceed and yes  We are
very happy that today we as the
University of Zurich and Z HdK
can design this breakdroom together with
our experts from Berlin
and Zurich and together with
them from the audience and as it has not
already been said, the floor is big, we
have it too  our lineup in the
dinosaur hall, where it's about the glaciers
and the retreat of the glaciers, how
we are transporting, and today
we're also trying to bring in the topic of
biodiversity and water,
especially with the guests
who are here,
which I find very comfortable, we
can get along now  always relate to the topics
that we have already heard about today.
Transdisciplinarity was a huge topic,
that's how Andreas and I work
together, too. Our teams are actually
always made up of a wide variety of disciplines.
Glaciologists, designers,
environmental psychologists, developers,
curators
or didactics  our project also has a
lot of quality and the team members are
also very motivated because we
learn a great deal from each other
and with the transdisciplinary we have
now also
arrived in our group
Zurich she was the author of a song
in the last ipc report in Chapter 2 on
adaptations to climate change and on the subject of
Europe and
water no mountains sorry then
Uwe Ulbricht from the Freie Universität
Berlin meteologist also researches
extreme weather events, especially
in the city of Berlin
Sandra Jasper Professor at the
geographic  Institute at the University
of Berlin, she made a film about
biodiversity, so she also has a
lot of experience in outreach and
Maria Magdalena Walter from the
Leibniz Institute for Aquatic Ecology,
she also dealt with the topic of
nature-based adaptation measures
and how to not only use
the physical  processes
but can also go a little
further
Fritz reussig would also have been invited and
accepted but for
private reasons he was
prevented from picking tonight and yes
we can do it without him we have
planned three chapters from the sequence first
the  Inventory we hear from the
researcher where it is urgent then the idea of
moving from knowledge to action what are measures what is good
practice and if there is still time there
might be something like a short thing
about 40 minutes because we do
n’t want the network dismantling either  Missing
is also very important for us, so
at the latest by 88 we'll be
finished
I'll come straight to the first chapter because
that's the nice situation now
the inventory the reason a
basic phenomenon of research is always
observation all knowledge
begins with observation and today
we also recognize the house is on fire
we want to know where you stand, dear
colleagues, with your
research, what is your
disciplinary perspective, the current
status and what are the latest
relevant enemies, so where does
that lead to where the fire is burning as your view and what is
your assessment  In this regard, there are
now four short ones in plaster with
a few slides to simply
have a starting position and know what
is popular in your discipline,
first Uwe Ulbricht thank you, yes, thank you very much,
I'll start with what you
all probably experienced more or
less  namely that we
had very dry summers, very dry years and you can see that in these
yellow areas, it is always the
deviation as it goes in the course of the year in
the individual years, how it is
getting bigger and wherever it is yellow it
is too dry, that means  we have had
real problems in the past
and that has had an effect in all
sorts of places it has
n't been too dry every year
and you ask yourself how does it
actually fit together how can what are there any
indications that there are more and more
dry years and that  is in
fact not the case
the
climate models that we look at but also
the data that we look at say the
annual precipitation does not change
but nevertheless what is happening what
can be there and what you see there
is this large graphic that is the
number  the number of dry days is increasing
all the time
okay now you can do some math
that fits together more and more
dry days and the overall
precipitation does not change that
means there must also be more heavy
precipitation and exactly this
combination is also a problem, especially
for the cities  we want to tackle the
urban area now here in a
larger project kliever funded by the Berlin
University Airlines I know it
is also transdisciplinary and real laboratory
and if you go to the next slide again
very briefly I would like to
tell you something else for us
relevant in that context what
you see in the lower part is the
temperature curve made a bit bigger
by
the past climate and you can see that
it's not just going straight up it's
definitely going up but there are
fluctuations and one of the things
we  have now developed in meteorology
are relatively new and are currently being
made new, which we also want to
use for research are so-called
decadal forecasts, we want to know
and we want to make use of them so that one
can look into the future into the near future and not just always  I have to say
what is the end of the century because
then you can
make adjustments or
set priorities at this time.
Thank you very much Uwe, by the way, we
agreed as a colleague before the
breakout session that you like to take
Andreas yes, so I come from
gladiology and  that is a bit far away
from Berlin but here in
Zurich in Switzerland you identify
with the glaciers what you see here
is the ice volume that has decreased
from 2000 to today from almost 80
cubic kilometers to 50
cubic kilometers
and what is now
the simplest way in the last few years
we have had a two to three percent
melt maybe most
of you can still remember the
summer of 2003 that was the extreme
event with almost four percent melt
but this summer topped everything we
have a loss of  6% of our
ice volume in Switzerland retracted
and that was quite an extreme
event to reconnect with you
so
we also use it in
communication.
It was really an extreme yes we have
never since we measured and for  Partly
we do that on glaciers up to 100
years back so much melt was measured in one
year and
of course that also has an effect on
various areas, the water balance,
the new see the nature
danger situation, tourism and
finally sea level rise because
the glass that  Water that does
n't just melt here in the Alps that
eventually reaches the sea
thanks Andreas
yes right now there's a short pump from
Maria Magdalena yes
from the
hut extreme events are heard and
of course they are the future and in the
urban context
the terms are often more natural too  Heard about urban heating
heat islands and so on and
in Berlin now the
fortunately has a lot of bodies of water,
a lot of large bodies of water too and
the condition of these bodies of water is
actually frighteningly bad and
too much due to too much construction and and
so almost the  Decline then natural
state no longer exists and
we are now trying to
work together because we have already
heard the interdisciplinarity today,
um similar to other cities with
nature-based solutions, to bring these waters
back to their original state, on
the one hand,
hydrologically speaking, these strong strong
discharges  to minimize those caused by extreme rain events and
thereby
reduce flooding, but at
the same time to
serve the social aspect somewhere and to
create local recreation areas, to create cool places for cooling,
to create green spaces, which
will be very very important in the future, especially in urban areas and there  Of
course, especially with something like this, the methods
and types of models and analyzes are
very important from a hydrological point of view,
but we have already discussed them with each other beforehand,
the
[music]
inclusion of these
nature-based solutions and social
aspects is also very, very important  to bring these
two disciplines together and
get the maximum out of it
thank you very much Maria then our
ruschka will say something about the overriding topic of
small change
okay I'll try in German this
morning I spoke in English
but I said to Niki okay I
'll try it a bit more informally so
maybe  I manage that on this
education is a bit of our
future and that is what we in the IPC
report stands for the Europe chapter and
we have these pictures when it comes to
communicating with for our Parliament
we were invited as science
scientists to our
Parliament in  Switzerland about the
results of this ipc direction we
diversity also IPs to uh present
advantages and that is a
bit of an edit of what is
in the ipc report for our future so what is
here are the core risks for
central Europe that uh a  a bit
unsustainable as said
level of this huge so me
a lot of these risks with
our state of global warming we
are there 1.1 now are already noticeable
as say they are moderate risks that
means these huge are already
attributed as says to climate change  and
then what stands in the future around 1.5 is that
many of these huge ones are a
bit high and if we don't
make it and
the reports now say that
probably we won't make it
with this income five we'll
see a bit but tomorrow there will be  also
this new
Cup 27 and a lot of new ones yes looked and
if we don't make it now we are
the forecast more between two 2.5 degrees of
warming and we see that the
ability of our cocosystem and us to
adapt
decreases decreases the crease but
positively it is  we also see in
this report this ipc report so there
are many solutions for adaptation and there
are a lot more than in the last
ten years and that is very a very
positive but what is also the problem
with adaptation what many of these
nature based measures for example  are
working or are no longer
effective with every increase in global
warming
thank you
now we would like to open the microphone
because we are not the
only experts here in the
room there are some in the
audience now maybe I would like to add
your point of view and  Research
burning hotspots or maybe
you have questions additions to what my
colleagues have said
are there any requests to speak from the group
hello I'm Christine Köhler I
work for quantis it's actually a
sustainability monitoring company
that comes from Zurich
but is also here in Berlin and I'm
from  also with the topic of communication
commitment because I think that was also
the topic here
and there you just want to ask
maybe something more about the
film and maybe also a few other
aspects that are in communication
and I also find this curve
for commitment  So first of all a
shock and awareness then maybe
acceptance and then okay now I can
do something and now I'll be active it's
like this
and whether you've worked with it before
I understood that as
a communication topic today
do a second part about
communication  project but
maybe there is
something you're welcome to say so I do
n't know if I can answer the question
so with the model maybe on
a personal level if I
tell you how this film
came about I've been
in Berlin and love for a long time
I have, so to speak, observed how the
city has changed over the years and
in Berlin there is always the question how
long have you been living in Berlin are you
in Berliner in Berliner I was
in Berlin for the first time in the late 90s
then in the early 2000s
moved here and had
a lot of experimental places in my immediate vicinity
urban gardens fallow a lot yes a lot of
experimental space if you just
talked to me about the city as a laboratory that’s what it looked like I
noticed over time
that these places are disappearing
more and more  Gaps are being filled, there is
construction
and so to speak no direct
shock moment, but long-term
observation together with my
research interest in urban nature
then led to me
and colleagues making a film about these
places, also precisely
because they were disappearing for
me  Exactly and this film is
a documentary it was only supposed to
be 15 minutes long in the end it is now
more than 70 minutes that is the tendency of
science to always go over time
maybe but it has become a very
nice instrument to tell this
story of the city of Berlin
but also tell the story, so to speak, of perhaps mediating the current crisis
or these
conflicts that exist in the city
between building, nature, protection,
social projects, which the places
have appropriated differently but also have to
disappear and that is exactly
the background, so to speak, and the film
is called natura urbaner  the fallow from
Berlin and whoever is interested in
the film just contact me
we have a youtube link for the
film
thank you Sandra there is another
question or addition comments from
your side
researching research observations
do you want to add something else we go
to the second  Part,
we have another question window so
we have the time for
feedback but it
should also be about communication
and we tried to
make his communication tool
that can also be seen in the entrepreneur hall.
Niklas will now briefly present it and then
we can then go back into the room
open
so I'll show you time-lapse through
climate policy and climate communication
you've already made some efforts
with moderate success we still see
climate psi ignorance and
resignation
I'll show you a first model
or concept of how to approach it
are actually three of Maren's recommendations
Urner, she is
a communication psychologist,
media psychologist and
neuroscientist and she says
climate communication is a great fight
against indifference and
repression and only when emotions
are involved can we get out of this attitude,
I don't care, so the facts
alone are not enough, we have to
tell a second story  The point
is the relationship level spatial,
temporal and human proximity are
important because they create dismay
and if these three proximity factors
are met then our brain switches
from passive to action mode
and very important but that has
now arrived not with the
problems description the
disaster reports but stop
show what solutions are in the room
because when we talk about problems
we get stuck there when we
talk about solutions solutions then
ideas for solutions also arise and that
brings me to our project I'm
not saying that it's the solution to all
problems but it's something like one
Good practice or best practice is in two
climate communication projects that Andreas
and I did with the
transdisciplinary teams,
where virtual reality is a
medium that can also trigger strong emotions
to tell the story of glaciers and the impact of
climate change on glatiology
kiospheres
and you will
also be able to find these projects below, above
all the expedition two degrees where you can
see a few excerpts here and I
think we made it the project
is no longer new is already three four
years old but I still like it
seen works very well and
reaches people on different
levels it has to do with the fact that the
emission in general makes it possible to experience
these realistic mountain panoramas
the animated glaciers shrink that
hits you that breathtaking in the
literal sense moving emotionally
moving too and then there is the
appealing  Storytelling that's the
john tiendl one of the early glaciologists
also climatologists he was the
first to describe the greenhouse effect one of the
first lives in the 19th
century and he takes us
back 100 years through this glacier history and
then forward 80 years and the whole thing
also happened very importantly  on the
hard data the only one and the
latest scenarios also
IPCC so everything is relatively precise and well-
founded and the third point last but
not least i think is the quality of the
design so the pictures are
also appealingly understandable and that
comes from our side with the
picture competence  know from knowledge and
ZHdK now we are on tour here
in Berlin too we are showing the exhibition and
we can then go to the Humboldt so
it will be on display there for another 8 months
you are all cordially invited
to look at it in peace and quiet
so I'm already
down  you can also experience it below
and with us it works with
the glaciers close by and that would
actually have been the transition
back to you you already
said something about this film in Berlin
you probably have to work with other topics
than with glaciers
maybe you can say something again
about that, yes, in any case,
the glaciers are of course only an indirect
topic, very, very indirectly, probably,
but
exactly, but of course it is important
to say again that the climate issue
is a topic that has meanwhile received a lot of
media attention  The
issue of biodiversity and the crisis of
species extinction is also a very big
crisis that perhaps
needs more stories in comparison and that's why
we
concentrated on nature in the city in the film, above
all on nature that
wasn't planned by people, i.e. you
often thinks of parks
and street trees, of course, but we have
a lot of nature that
develops, so to speak, that also
develops differently than
outside of the city, so nature
goes through genetic mutations,
new species arise new combinations
of species that only through the
city and  which are the only influences of the
city
and also to get away a little there
is always the problem
in biodiversity or in
ecosystem research with the so-called
invasive species but also to
get away a little from this idea that
is very strongly anchored in our western thinking that is
nature is something original that
is worth protecting and has always
been there and doesn't change but that
's a very fixed idea of ​​nature
and instead of nature that shows quite nicely that
's very dynamic and
constantly changing nature in the city thanks and
Maria, when you are
out and about with your projects, how do you try to
take people with you,
so if we
go out and take samples, for example,
we definitely have our small,
I don't want to say, laboratory there, but we
also have our equipment and the
various samples  Containers and we
filter the water and sometimes stand
on the bridges and get the water
out with the bucket and
the people often stay, you just look
very suspiciously at what is going to happen, often
people really stop
and ask what to do again
and then  let
's say we take water samples
we look at this and that then
we had recently but a
student made the mistake of saying
that we test the water PCR that was
n't so good um but um yeah it's
just often people when when they
stand still when you
start talking a bit are quite
interested, so of course you have to simplify the whole thing
and then you ca
n't talk about isotopes and ideas and all
these things, the analyzes we
do, but simply say in general
why we do it and often it is then
actually mostly there's always a lot of
understanding and I've also heard
from often older people who, for
example, know the rivers where we are, who
still know them before they were renatured
and say ah yes, you see, now
it's much nicer and much
[music]
nicer  the surroundings than before and
that only very briefly to the deviation that
also brings me to what was just
said before that when it
comes to hydrology and bodies of water that
often this this urge to somehow
contain and and to control
very so especially in the  today it
just fails so it's much
more of working with nature and with the
runs and and than
instead of against it because you
kind of just crash against a wall and
in that respect it's similar to that with the
communication that you just when you're
on the people  approaching and explaining
then you often meet with
understanding and
um another example that I also
heard on the radio recently is
this and before that
these actions where people stick to the
Autobahn and so I think it's
a very good thing for everyone  big I don't want to say
annoyed because traffic jams and and we
just heard a news
accidents happen emergency lanes etc and
the radio presenter's suggestion was
why not take the glue and
go to elementary school or daycare and
do something with the children there
or or who somehow bring it up and learn
something about nature learn about
climate change learn about learn about species
learn about and somehow
start earlier and give them a certain
awareness of it and then
also in the sense of sustainability that
we the young generation somehow already on it
bring and raise awareness
of what's happening and that they're
already
going into the future with passion and look,
thank you
generations of students who came by
how has that changed
communication with the small
generations of students that you
've already established how has it changed  the
perception go or your teaching
so I would now say communication
that it
has changed really great as far as students are concerned,
but what I would like to mention maybe to
bring in another aspect here
is a larger project
that we are involved in, I'm only a
scientist
Communication is always a
bit difficult to get across
what is relevant, so
we have engineers in the project climate in
words at the change, so climate and
water under changes and
what is only promoted by the university,
we also have
the problem there  that
many people are aware that water
is a problem
and that starts with the fact that,
for example, in the west of Berlin and
in the south of Berlin they are
getting lower and lower, so there is less and less
lake level and one wonders
what the reason is  what can you do
the administration,
from the senate administration to Berliner
Wasserbetriebe and things like that, are
also dealing with such problems and we are now trying
to tackle them in a transdisciplinary way that is
a particular challenge
and I will put it back to the lakes
there is an attitude  that ultimately
measures would help renaturation where
the discussion then came up did
this river ever exist and there is an
attitude here these are all the people who
drilled their wells and keep
their lawn green there despite the great drought
and that’s why the more the
lake level sings  so there is
great potential for conflict, especially in
this water area in the Berlin
area and then also politically Berlin and
Brandenburg next door, do
people even talk to each other
or how do you get them
to talk to each other,
what are the scientists doing
with the story at all, well, we
are
still trying to establish the basics and perspectives
to work out and to bring this
communication how is it
on a basis that
is not just emotional
and well I'm just a
scientist I think that's
a good idea
well then I'll be happy to open it again if
someone has a question yes
Thank you very much, you can listen to it
very briefly Andreas Taubert University of Potsdam
I'm Swiss in Brandenburg for 16
years,
so I got both sides of it
Herbicides etc pp
on the basis of
renewable raw material sources,
i.e. converting agricultural waste
into activated carbon that is a
good project that you can communicate well, but
the difficulty is that it
is an incredibly small-scale communication yes I go to schools
I go to the semesters and so
on  and so on and
I think one of the questions that we or
at least I would throw into the round
is how do we get
communication more effective
because I can't go to every school
yes we all struggle with the same
problems or very similar ones  Problem,
but everyone does it for themselves,
yes, and I'm curious about
all the people here with me
work and
that is a challenge but the
communication there is something
that can be improved and I'll say it again
now ne is the
science way to improve science is the
cooperation between the different
scientific disciplines and
science locations there
is of course certainly
a  nice partner but
now here in the Berlin and
Brandenburg area we have a
network I don't know if you
know Geox
where it's actually funded and
we're happy that it's
going to continue for the next five years
maybe some feedback from  on
my part because I think that your
question also addresses design and I
keep postulating that
science communication is also a
discipline that generates a lot of know-how,
a lot of experience, there are also theories
about it and we have to sit down
and take a close look at what exactly it is  your
goals what is the target audience do you want to impart
knowledge do you want to raise awareness do you want to
create concern is there
no answer
you would have to enter into a cooperation
what we have been doing with Andreas
for years for example the relevant
media also find the tests do you make
a trailer error and  Brings
trust building and what is important from my
experience is that you
also give the design or
the artist trust in both directions and
leave an empty process open in both directions. These are actually the
good projects where you
can reach a good goal on an equal footing
Yes, considering the audience, I would
also say again that
science communication
is extremely important,
but it
is difficult for many
scientists,
especially young scientists, because it is not
appreciated, so we have to do it
so to speak, in addition to what
we do otherwise, we still have to
continue to publish and because
there are hardly any instruments to evaluate all this
communication that we do
a documentary lasts
two years it is basically a book
but it is not read like a
book  and that is also a very important
structural topic in the background that is
very important to us that this
science communication is also
valued in for
young scientists
we would have actually thought of
doing something like a flashlight
some of you have now addressed it
your research and mediating
experience so the highlights are where do
you have this lever in
communication that can then perhaps also
make contributions to social transformation where did
you experience and feel it there are so short
and sweet success stories you still
want to share the question works but  also
to the audience because there is a lot of
expertise here, there are projects where I
want to draw our colleagues’ attention to
experiences that are important from your point of view,
maybe we can do another round like this
if someone has a message
that the many initiatives are
incredibly important, I think so
I think it was also made clear, but
this question of being able and
wanting to scale is a problem for
science, for us, for
the media too, if you
look at climate communications there is no
space or it takes
place somewhere and it is strong
Reports are driven by events, etc.,
and I believe that the development
of formats that are repeatable,
retrievable, or
reporting formats that the
scientists could also use, that
time series are created, that there is continuity,
that there is a certain look and
recognisability, are really
important, I believe  in order to be able to
scale, so to speak, but look, there
is just no reporting where
something is actually done every day
or Corona reporting was
also done every day, which could have been done with the
quality, you can argue with it, but
this type of reporting, which, so to speak,
tries to do it over a longer period of time
development that would
otherwise get lost or who still
remembers the yes, I think that's
an important point, but
science should somehow
try to develop both graphic and optical
concepts and of course
then you need media partners who
can implement it and  some of them are missing
too,
but you can develop that very
important vote two or three weeks ago we were at
the K3 climate
conference, it was in Zurich with us at
the zhtka it was a central topic,
many media houses do that today there are
media formats there  pressure in
this direction and that helps
maybe I can say something even
when it comes to the IPCC yes these are
these global reports and for us the
problem is that there is so much in it
and there are so many different,
as I said,
disciplines disciplinary  or so big
that we work
as said it is very difficult for
example to bring these together and
we have worked a lot and our
graphics and in the end we have for
example in our
policemaker there is no picture and the
capsules is one and all page long like that
we used a page
to explain these pictures so maybe we
need this cooperation also with
graphic artist and also with because quite
science we believe or that is
quite clear but if we took this
picture that I showed with us
and I said yes  we
need something for our you
said for our parliamentary a
picture and then that has for us the picture
was totally clear but it took a while until
we really brought this picture that you
might understand but yes then
we might need this together
with people
answers  then yes it needs pictures
that sounds so easy to you physics
in fact would give you the following to consider
if you actually want to convey complex data like the ones that
have just been created here
pictures or let's say you
want to convey them visually then by
processing it visually and by looking at it
narratively and inventing a story
again and that has to be
played back, that is, it is
actually an interaction
where you can imagine that it
sometimes hurts the sciences
because the view is simply different
because the reception is because that is what it is
assume that the
message is supposed to get through, yes,
a different message at all, in part,
with the same content on the
same basis, the same integrity does
not require any discussion at all, so that will
ask you again, what does
this
science communication look like as a trans and
interdisciplinary discipline, so
maybe  Would you like to
say something to Niklaus about how your cooperation
was in this project
as scientists we are
also very concerned with the uncertainties
of the models and that is very
difficult to transport if you
try to simplify it so much that
you can also use it in a VR  one can
then perhaps show two scenarios
that more or less
convey the uncertainties, but there is
still a lot that we are
really dealing with
think of
hurricanes that are heading for some areas
and the question of how to convey
that this is, so to speak, then also
leads to people taking action
and who don't just say it's
not now it doesn't matter
and getting that across is a task
that is  clearly recognized
the challenge in my opinion
with this science communication
is
that the scientists
remain happy with the fact that something is
being communicated that is very
catchy but de facto wrong
and that happened very quickly I
now have a larger event with some colleagues
done there should be
talked to the press afterwards
also went to the water area
and there were some who
said I don't do that anymore I do
n't talk to the press anymore because what
comes out there is terrible
there the word immunity was
turned on you that's what I did  never said that it
needs professionals who actually do this mediation
maybe I'm
not one of them
either, the press press
certainly does mediation to
society I mean that's their
job what else
but I think we do and that
's what I think  IPC is a good
example of where actually very
successful despite all the
difficulties and actually everyone
knows, firstly, there are these reports,
secondly, what do they essentially say
and that's what I would say, we've
already had a success story,
maybe we'll write something about it then  it
came to me from today and
that was the news but
we've been saying that I don't know for a long
time and there's space
maybe I too maybe it's about the
media it's about communication and
maybe we as scientists
have to find us too  a way that we
can communicate that we are
heard because sometimes it goes a
bit in these big reports
or in this big one and then they do
n't find this information and then
in the media it comes much faster
and yes but
well one last question  and then
we'll soon be going to an aperitif,
but maybe we're thinking in the classic way,
so when we look at this project,
this project has
n't decided to go to the media at all,
but rather directly to the
children, to the young people, to the
population and places  are just not
known and now I would like to go to the
excess mortality curve that you just
mentioned I
liked that a lot what does it look like
with the
interpretation and look behavior
of our recipients that is
so I wanted to make two points there
I don’t think so and  I am quite
convinced that uncertainties cannot be
communicated, so just as an
example if we look at what
people read in the newspaper before the pandemic
and today I believe
the educational effect that you
can read functions today that make a change over time
is the greatest benefit and
an example is the
excess mortality curve that
practically everyone can read today and the success
of it has been repeated many times
and the presentation and the graphic
presentation was very very accurate so I
am sure that the
educability of how people
absorb information is much much higher
the problem  is so I'll say again
the one and a half goal is from my point of view a
maybe how important for politics
but
completely irrelevant for personal concern
so again in Zurich the
temperature ranges between -15 and plus
35 degrees from the coldest to the autumn day is
50 degrees and a half  Degrees are about
three percent I never go and I
understand the difference between weather
and climate perfectly I never go out and
say today is one and a half degrees warmer
than yesterday
and I think we should really
be careful that if we have
unrealistic goals, we don't do emotional ones
have a connection one and a half degrees has no
emotional connection we can
communicate as long as we want to
understand conceptually why one and a half
degrees is important but if the narrative
does not trigger personal concern
then the stories can tell for hours
it will not
change anything today it is important that  it
triggers a narrative of personal concern because all social
media communicate personal concerns
i would think a lot more about it
if i wanted to achieve a scaling effect
which personal
concerns can i trigger at all
i can say something on the 1.5 degree yes
i have that for me  also thought i was
in a school they were all little
kids not so little it was ten eleven
and then i did my slide a
bit like here and i said
these 1.5 degrees how can i explain that
and i think a simple way  is I
said a little bit
you can imagine that you have the
temperature is 37 degrees and you are
normal you are outside what happens
if e.g. your body temperature is
38.5 degrees or 39 and then you
started to understand that what
happens what you  other and I
counted this effect a bit
and then we talked together
and then I think it was a bit
more noticeable what does 1.5 degrees mean, that
's the issue of generation that
Michael, yes you mentioned, so how do
I tell it  History and is very
important and I also like to take the ball
that dukarin my rectori
passed to the pictures are enormously
important we also talk about the power
of pictures and we experienced it today
the architect tells us the whole
story of this urban development in
Africa and that  the picture came of the
beach before the urban gardening
renaturation and after that
you understand it and experience it
emotionally understand what is at stake here
what quality is gained and I
think there is still a lot to be done because
for us designers it is
everyday for them  Craftsmanship because every picture is
always a story we develop the
concepts for it, but we have to
develop that in dialogue with them, so that
Uwe also meets your requirements, that
's still precise and correct,
but it also reaches people
by showing the right pictures  and
stories told
on the other hand think we have to
get it from this
picture always remains abstract emotional in its way
but still abstract because it
is difficult to communicate the one and a half degrees in a picture, for example,
you also need
numbers for that and so
it would be in my dream world  why that you
think about it when you talk to something and
that you know very early on, for
example, this handling of data and
its presentation, yes, that is a
different discipline than yours, but
somehow
a link would have to be found at some point because that's the way it is,
of course  whether you have a certain
complexity, the topic comes and now you
have to be able to read it, so
excess mortality is then
somehow difficult to do with a photo, well well,
many of them are quite a but then it’s
a bit again, so
how do we manage to sort of make it
legible again  to be integrated into
society differently than through pictures, on
the other hand, through stories, thirdly,
through emission and emotionality, but
fourthly, factually, that's as
reading decreases, especially
scientific knowledge,
one last word and then let's go there was still
here I just wanted to do it
again  maybe from an experience so
we're a
science based consultancy that
does life cycle assessments and all sorts of backwards and I'm in the
communications engagement side and
maybe just again that's exactly
what's the target audience where are they in
their in their development for some
cameras  made more detailed at the
beginning of
this touch it has to be a bit simpler
we use pictures that is very
very important and also equivalences so
what can you
do with so CO2 many can not do anything with then it is
what is an equivalence ne so how many
cows how many so  something where they
deal with ne so I found this closeness to be a
very important point, not just emotionally
but is the closeness to it
and what I just wanted to say is
that even within a
consulting firm, these two it is
very rare that you have these two together  do
n't want green motion that's why
we work very
science-based ourselves but it's a
learning process between the
scientists and the
communication people i can also
say for myself that you
need more mutual exchange
and then we bring that to the customers the
two of them the other point  i
wanted to bring i am american german
american and
in the 90s the
ebay founder established the gold a
prestical media because the
americans are maybe a bit quicker to
take hollywood and movies and films to
engage awareness and also engagement activity and if  what
interests you, please Media, is this
company that was then established at the time
through pictures because of the Schulz was
brought out there and then to
connect that right away with how can you
get involved and change that you
know here, I think, came after that maybe that’s
just  just
as a reference
thank you very much looking at the clock
I also wanted to say another photo
of it running you can connect it we
also have other complex areas of
social reporting or, for
example, economic reporting and
the debate about the emergence of
indicators is always a dispute as to what
is  the right indicator and so on
and thus partly competing
institutes that measure according to different and with
different methods and so on
i think that would be an
alternative to a pure
setting of goals namely to have the debate
recurring debate about what
are the indicators how is measured
etc that could  also more, so to speak,
trigger communication that was just a
quotation mark annual report has
and similar
well thank you very much I think we will
pick up I may very sincerely demodium
a small open
[applause] thank you
very much thank you